[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
is that Tony Michaels podcast real and
raw political and social commentary the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty you [ __ ] eating
[ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of speech
this is the Tony Michaels podcast and
this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
welcome Monday morning
[Music]
Martin Luther King Jr day
federal holiday
here in our country for good reasons
Dr Martin Luther King Jr is the father
of woke Republicans don't seem to
understand that
I guess they've never read anything
besides the line I have a dream
we're going to listen to an excerpt of
the letter from Birmingham Jail today
where Dr King talks about complicit
moderate whites
as I was doing my workout this morning I
was thinking hard
about what MLK Day means
to me
and why it means
what it means
I grew up in white Rural America
there was no very few people of color in
the town I grew up in I'm still today
the schools where I where I went to
still do not let out
for Martin Luther King Jr day
they don't find it important enough
you'll see a lot of Republicans
quoting
Martin Luther King
Jr today now I'm saying he's a
republican I've seen this already that
he was a Republican
and clearly
there is a very high number of people
it's a lower percentage but it's a high
number of people in this country
do not quite understand
exactly the legacy of Dr Martin Luther
King the reason why
is because they do not have
the experience of being a black person
in this country just like me I do not
have that experience I didn't grow up
with that experience
that it's not the culture I live in I
lived in white Nash white Christian
nationalist country
and that's the institution in which
delivered me who Martin Luther King Jr
was and what it was about
and as I ponder it as I think about it
I think about our theme music here
the the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty
it's what we all strive for in this
country doesn't matter if you were born
here
you were brought here as a child if you
came here as an adult
whether you came here legally or
illegally
you're here you're America
that's what we are
there was one thing that Dr King in his
writings and his speeches
seem to understand more than any other
American before him and maybe even after
him
is that the fundamental right to decency
the fundamental right to decency
is the thing that binds us all as humans
there's a quote
from the letter from the Birmingham Jail
it says without Justice there can be no
peace
he who passively accepts evil
is as much involved in it as he who
helps to perpetrate it
if you stand back
and you watch intolerance and you
tolerate
intolerance
you are passively accepting that
intolerance
it is crucial
to our society
to our citizens to our fellow [ __ ]
humans
not just inside our borders but around
the world
that we must not stand back and
passively accept the intolerance
the rise
of right-wing ideology all around the
world
that is trying to stop equality and
equity
because of fear that they may have
something taken away from them if
someone is given something else
as if it's currency
and Dr King and its heart really
understood
what this country had to do
to make amends it'll take a long time
folks I don't know if you know this
but during the first part of our history
white rich Americans owned other human
beings
own them as property
we fought a war over slavery no matter
what they want to say about states
rights
if you want to go there it's the state's
rights to own slaves
they were brought here in chains for
crying out loud
against their will
forced to be farm animals
they were farm animals
and every single Institution
from the day that this country was
thought in the brains of our founding
fathers
never
not once
had black Americans people of color
anywhere in this country
as part of the foundation
of those institutions
and until you as a white person
really truly understand
what racism is and what it looks like
Through The Eyes
of a black person's experience
listen to them
they will tell you they're not scared to
tell you
me as a white man does not have the
capability
of experiencing
what racism and institutional racism
truly is
but we must listen to each other
and I want to listen to part of the
Birmingham Jail there's a recording of
Martin Luther King Jr
reading the letter from the jail in
Birmingham and he's talking about
moderate whites
and it reminds me so much of the back
and forth we have today and the stupid
word that the right uses woke yes I put
it in the title you don't like it [ __ ]
you I don't care
because I've questioned several times on
the show what the [ __ ] are they talking
about when they're talking about woke
and wokeism I mean Jesus Christ it's
their entire personality trait now
their entire personality trait is
anti-wokism whatever the [ __ ] that means
and maybe just maybe on today
MLK Day
maybe just maybe
maybe we can figure that out
what woke actually means
I'm not sure exactly what they're
talking about I mean come on we know the
code word
we know the code words
they think we're scared of the word
liberal they think we're scared that
democracy is weak
they think we're frightened of them
and that's why
that's why they are weak
when they say today when you see someone
say that Martin Luther King Jr was a
great Republican
from a Republican
they're hiding
they're hiding behind the truth
because the truth is
and Martin Luther King if wokism is what
they say it is
the father of woke
and I want
um
everyone to know that you can't shy away
from these conversations I know
um I I talked to a lot of white folks
before of course
and
some very racist deep-seated racism
that is born out of the lies told about
Martin Luther King Jr using him as a
cudgel man for that very racism
but I've had many conversations with
white people saying that they don't know
how to have a conversation without
offending someone
who cares offend them
offend them that's right
for us to get where we need to be
in our democracy
for equality and equity and liberty for
every single person who is within our
borders I don't care if you were born
here I don't care if you were brought
here I don't care if you stepped over to
an imaginary line if you're here you're
here
you're human
you should be
treated with decency
but until us as a nation as a whole
and not just the majority because
there's the majority of the country now
I believe the majority of the country is
liberal
I believe the majority of the country
believes that the intolerance that is
happening
is evil and accepting it passively as Dr
King would say
only helps to perpetrate it
not just here all around the world we
watched as
the the Nazis here in this country
stoked the Nazis in Brazil to a fake
insurrection
TV it was great TV for him
but until we
as the pro-democracy coalition
look at each other in one resounding
voice say
we will not tolerate your intolerance
because I believe that's what wokeism is
right
isn't that what they're truly saying
is that we the the woke left
are against intolerance
you goddamn right I am
and if that's what it means to be
woke
Count Me In
that's what it means to be liberal
will Count Me In
if that's what it means to be on the
left
Count Me In
I do not believe
that us as the intolerant left because
that's what they're going to call us
today
you should attack them
that's right anyone who appropriates
Martin Luther King
in one of their posts or one of their
statements
and on the other hand
they perpetrate this narrative
that accepts evil
when they say they're they're going to
kill lokism
what the [ __ ] do you think it is
when you wake up and realize
not the only way
to get to equity and equality in this
democracy
is to be intolerant
of intolerance
I appreciate you joining me here on
Monday morning
we are trying to get to 20 000
subscribers and so you can help me
that would be fantastic
the mods are pushing for it we have the
greatest moderators in the world to
match the greatest audience in the world
two years we've been doing this
I don't know if today is the anniversary
or Friday technically it was January
14th which was Saturday so I think today
is our two year anniversary here at the
Tony Michaels podcast two years of Tony
as the moderators call it
so go to the tonymichaels.com show your
support
but more importantly when you go to the
Tony michaels.com make sure you go to
the YouTube channel there's a link there
go to the YouTube channel And subscribe
now if you're on another platform again
go to
thetonymichaels.com and show us your
support
I I mean if you want to go to the Tony
Michaels and give monetary support it's
there if you want to give in the tip jar
it's there the podcast fund is there
but more than anything
more than anything I need your help
spreading the message and spreading the
word
that's what we need
more than anything in this country and
I'm going to keep yelling and screaming
into the microphone as long as I
possibly can
as long as I got enough ludens and Halls
still
when I talk my sinuses release the
drainage and it
causes me to have a little bit of a
cough so
I feel great I feel fantastic I worked
out this morning
I thought a lot about what the show was
going to be today
when I worked out
and I want to get Gabe Sanchez's
perspective on MLK day because I know
his is completely different
he has a completely different life
experience than I have as do you your
life experience
is absolutely different than mine
or
or Gabe Sanchez's and that is the most
important thing that's why the diversity
works so well in this country that's why
it is an asset
for equality and equity
that's why they want that's why they
don't like it that's why they don't want
it
and they meaning the right you're going
to see this a lot we're probably going
to pull up a lot of really bad takes
today
um I I want to shoot down these bad
takes so what I want to do [ __ ] them and
we're going to talk about a few other
things that happened over the weekend
and we're going to go back to this
documents thing because we got to keep
this
um the messaging on this appropriate
because everyone including the media is
forgetting
that the Trump documents case with the
intent and the obstruction
is the thing that makes it Criminal
not just
a scandal it makes it criminal you
[ __ ] boneheads so we're gonna go over
a few things like that today but again I
appreciate all your support here at the
Tony Michaels podcast remember we air
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
on YouTube Twitter and twitch
simulcasting from the Midas touch
Facebook page look if you do me a huge
favor this would be the biggest favor
you give me all year
is subscribe to the YouTube channel and
not only that don't just subscribe the
gift is this because it's easy to
subscribe and then you can hit the
notifications and all that to make sure
that you watch every single show
but here's what I want you to do I want
you to send the link to three your
friends family friends co-workers
maybe someone who will like it maybe
someone who will hate it ah it doesn't
matter to me send that link to from the
YouTube channel the three of your
friends ask them to subscribe as well we
are trying to get to twenty thousand it
is a goal of ours
I think we can I think we can do it by
the beginning of February we're almost
to we're getting close we're closing in
on 14 000 I believe it's only 6 000 and
some change left let's do this
we have thousands of people watch and
listen every single day if everyone gets
three people to subscribe we'll be to 20
000 in no time so again the gift is this
if you want to give a gift if you want
to give support right now to the Tony
Michaels podcast the thing I'm asking is
that you subscribe and you share it with
three other people and see if they'll
share it
if they'll share it and we'll we'll grow
the audience
but more importantly
we will get this message to more and
more people
which for 2024 is the most important
thing
because if you think that these [ __ ]
boxes that we're going to go through
today with the horrible takes
on Martin Luther King and his legacy
are the worst thing that can happen wait
until 2024 there are going to be more
and more vile and more gross than even
George Santos folks these people are
frauds these people are liars
and they will continue to get worse and
worse and worse
as their orange Mussolini Jesus
gets trapped inside of a corner further
and further and further I don't know if
you noticed this
my Twitter timeline and noticed this
over the last week and this is just a
good example of how desperate they are
and I want to talk about this today I
want to show you a few of these [ __ ]
videos that these nincompoops are
[ __ ] posting they're posting videos
that are two and three years old
claiming they have some kind of context
with bad side effects
of a vaccine
outside of context and actual reality
they act like this video just posted
just became something
of course the comments light them up
pointing out that this video
is an old video
folks they're in full propaganda mode
I don't know if you know this
but they're propaganda mode
is to create a narrative
around the vaccine and to create it
around the coronavirus because they're
dying from it I don't know if you
noticed the unvaccinated or dying
from this new variant it's a [ __ ]
especially if you're not vaccinated it's
a [ __ ]
and it is killing bastards all over the
country
all demographics age sex
race it doesn't matter it is killing
them if they're not vaccinated
and they're leaning into it
and they're going to lean into it harder
when these committees start to form in
Congress and they start to attack
people and scientists who devoted their
entire lives
to helping save Americans from viruses
like Anthony fauci these [ __ ]
wouldn't even know who Anthony fauci was
if Donald Trump wouldn't have used him
as a scapegoat for the blame that should
have been placed on him
and it's all over the timeline
but they're trying they're trying their
best to spread their narrative and our
reaction should be to mock them
should be to to absolutely trudge them
but also amplify our message
we have to have a national narrative we
have to have one Coalition of messaging
for pro-democracy
to combat the right wing in this country
taking more and more control over our
governments not just the federal
governments the states and the counties
the school boards and the like
and they're using absolute 100 lies to
try to do that and to try to scare you
and to try to scare the citizens of this
country into handing over power to them
we cannot let it stand
we must act
and the way we Act is spread the message
so that is why I ask you to please share
the Tony Michaels podcast with your
family and your friends also follow us
at Twitter at Tony Michaels pod you can
also download every single episode
that's hugely important
downloading every single episode on
Apple Spotify Google whichever podcast
director you use you know if you go
subscribe
and set up to where it automatically
downloads you don't have to listen to
the whole thing just listen to the first
30 minutes or fast forward if you don't
like to listen to me rant then you can
fast forward 30 minutes that's what we
do I don't know if you noticed that
format I do the first 30 minutes as a
rant the a block as it's called in the
business
the a block
here at the show
and then we bring in the co-host and we
bring in our guest
and we uh we we bring the video evidence
we surf the Tweety tweets and the trendy
Trends and the shitless Roundup
so maybe you like the shitless better
maybe you like the rant better I don't
know
you tell me
you tell me what you like better and the
way you can tell me is to go download
every single episode and listen to it
you know the great part is how do I talk
really fast
this morning I wanted to go slow because
I wanted to get my thoughts precise
um again I was working out this morning
I was thinking about it and I wanted to
get my thoughts precise on Martin Luther
King Day
but normally I go pretty fast normally
I'm talking pretty fast but if you go
and download the episode you can
actually what you can do is you can
actually
you can hit
fast forward you can you can speed it up
a bit
so if you speed it up
it becomes faster so you can take the
first 30 minutes
and you can listen to it in just a few
so do that for me this is this is super
important that we get this message out
there
um and by you listening
is not just quite enough we have to
spread the message so share it with
someone that's what I'm here for that's
why I record this every day so you can
go share it you don't have to try to
regurgitate everything you don't have to
try to remember everything I say Jesus
Christ if you remember everything I say
in two hours
you're hired
but remember you can share every single
episode and that's important we're also
on Facebook follow us at the Tony
Michaels at the Tony Michaels if you're
on uh might as such Facebook right now
head on over to our Facebook page give
us a follow over there but most
important subscribe we're trying to get
to 20 000 subscribers two years of Tony
20 000 subscribers is our goal you're
the best audience in the world
and we love having you here even the
haters I see you haters most of the
haters are out there on Facebook you
ever notice that
most of the eaters are out there on
Facebook it's because it's a [ __ ]
dumpster fire over there on Facebook
and I tend not to block people yet
because we don't have that many people
following so I don't really pay
attention seeing a lot of [ __ ] over
on Facebook but hey come on in come on
in you [ __ ] kickers you [ __ ] eating
morons let's have fun
and come hate watch every single day for
all two hours that's one thing that I
like to Pat myself on the back for
because he's he's [ __ ] moglodytes
these trumpsters
they come and they watch this show for
two full hours they [ __ ] love
watching me oh my God they love watching
me they can't believe it so as you're
sharing this
as you're sharing this with your family
and friends dude do you not forget to
drop this
in your DM thread or your text thread
with your good old Trump supporting
Uncle Earl everyone
stick around we'll be right back right
after this
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another
momentum we're
to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the show
Monday January 16th
Martin Luther King Jr day here in this
country did you know
I don't know if you know this out there
and maybe you some of you folks are in
some of these areas
but there are actually schools out there
that are not out today it's one of the
only federal holidays that some of these
white rural schools do not release their
students on they're like oh yeah every
other federal holiday sure absolutely
hell we'll take a couple days for that
federal holiday ah couple for that one
couple for this one
MLK day and [ __ ] that [ __ ]
2023
2023
and schools will not release their white
students and they
and they wonder they wonder why we mock
them when they say things like CRT oh we
don't want that CRT we don't want the
truth we don't want the truth we don't
want the truth about the evils
that my grandpappy did
to people to to other people's families
who are still here where I don't want to
hear about it it'll make me feel guilty
about my racism look
if you hear
facts
about what has happened in the past
and you get [ __ ] white guilt because
of it and you think it's your fault it
is your racism talking to you okay
you do not you do not have to you do not
have to wallow
in that it is your fault
now you know what is your fault just
what Martin Luther King said in the
Birmingham Jail letter without Justice
there can be no peace he who passively
accepts evil is as much involved in it
as he who helps to perpetrate it
remember this remember these words it is
wokism I've been trying to figure out
what the [ __ ] Republicans what the [ __ ]
the America First Nazi party has been
talking about when they say woke
and I found this quote
from the Birmingham Jail letter that
Martin Luther King Jr wrote
and I believe
that this is the wokism that they are
trying to kill
the wokism the woke left liberals as if
these are scary [ __ ] words get the
[ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
I believe I found it
here it is uh
without Justice there can be no peace
he who passively accepts evil is as much
involved in it as he who helps to
perpetrate it
wokeism
no justice no peace
and he who stands back
and the Luts
intolerance
happened
is just as much involved as Dr King says
as the one who holds that intolerance
so
we cannot be afraid of this cycle we
cannot be afraid
to be intolerant of intolerance we must
speak out we must use our voice
and it is time for the Democratic
Coalition in this country and I'm not
saying Big D I'm seeing small
pro-democracy people people who truly
believe that democracy can deliver us
equity and equality
through the voice of the people the
ballot the vote
not no [ __ ] gerrymandering like we
have in the House of Representatives now
because we all know
if the Republicans would not have been
successful at gerrymandering the house
districts we would have
a speaker Hakeem Jeffries In This Moment
In This Moment On This Martin Luther
King Day
if we the Democracy would not have
allowed
Republicans
to gerrymandered districts
to make sure that the minority ideology
held power in Our House of
Representatives
we would have the first black man and
Speaker of the House
it is up to us in 2024
to do better
to hold ourselves accountable to our
messaging to our narrative
to our amplification that's right it is
up to you
now you have to listen to pro-democracy
speech
you have to come here every day maybe
three or four times a week maybe every
single day for two full hours
I will give you the cathartic release
I will get I promise you I promise you
this I promise you
I will give you the cathartic release I
will give you the energy I will give you
the Strategic outrage
to go out there and to make sure
that the pro-democracy messaging the
program knocker pro-democracy narrative
is at the Forefront in our country I
will give it to you every single day
two hours of it hell we might go to
three hours if we can get enough support
that's right
it's very hard to do two hours three
hours is even more difficult
just like oh well it's just time it's
just time yeah uh yeah
but show your support for the show
spread the message around
and do me that favor that would be the
greatest gift in 2023
is if we can grow this show and grow
this podcast
to be something that everyone's talking
about
I say some crazy [ __ ]
oh I see some crazy [ __ ] I don't know
you
you can ask Gabe Sanchez when he gets on
here I see some crazy [ __ ]
and I want to say more crazy [ __ ]
I believe we can get the attention not
just not just
of the right wing but I think I think
with your with you as such a great
audience
I think we can get the attention
of some of these defeatists on the left
some of these morons that have no idea
what they need to do to win politics
you know what I'm talking about I bash
them all the time and I don't give a
[ __ ] The Young Turks David packman
the list could go on and on and on here
weak
weak
absolutely weak in their messaging weak
and leaning into democracy
defeatism
defeatism
[Laughter]
well I will not be defeated
liberalism is the strength of our
democracy it is the strength of our
country it is the foundation of who we
are as a people humans decency
and with democracy
our democracy the people's government
we
can deliver equity and equality for
everyone in this country here's what
we're going to do uh we're Gabe Sanchez
is going to be joining us here in just a
moment and we're going to go listen to
the
uh recording
of Dr King but we also have a lot of
stuff to show you today I I have some
things I want to get to uh we want to
talk about Dr Martin Luther King on this
day remembering him as we should every
single day and remembering he is the
father of woke so let's do this let's go
let's go to the [ __ ] list Roundup we
round up all the Tweety tweets and
trendy Trends start the countdown
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome back to the Tony
Michaels podcast we've reached the part
of the show where we round up all the
280 tweets and trendy trends of the day
of course the number one trending thing
in this country today
is MLK Day
you'll see um here
Dr King MLK day happy MLK hashtag civil
rights
um
you're going to see a lot of shitty
takes today
um You're Gonna Hear Dr Martin Luther
King referred to as a republican a lot
like a lot
they think
that that gives them the ability
you know to be racist ah Dr Martin
Luther King when he was Republican
so we can be anti-woke we can make sure
that we're not for equality and equity
in this country
because he was a republican for crying
out loud jeez Louise don't you know that
excuse me I still have just Just a Touch
just a touch of the cough
um
trending number 10 is Birmingham Jail
um appropriately because of the letter
now again you're going to have a lot of
folks on the right
doing this whole I have a dream they're
gonna quote that a lot
and they're also going to quote
the content of his character I'm gonna
say that a lot too today and say a lot
of that [ __ ]
right
they're not gonna they're not gonna tell
the truth are they Gabe Sanchez I doubt
it they're not going to tell the truth
or are they they never do
these are merchants of Lies I like
George Santos I wonder if George Santos
is related to Martin Luther King Jr
surely somewhere he's probably yeah
would would claim that I mean
[Laughter]
I honestly could see him in a video
right now I can see the image of him on
Steve bannon's [ __ ] traitor TV with
his new butt buddy Matt gants and
they're talking about and he says yeah
well I I did my my family tree and I am
related to Dr Martin Luther King Jr yeah
well the thing about the thing about
family trees and George Santos is he
just goes to a store and then picks one
up or rather he just like he just like
digs one out of someone else's front
yard like a little baby one you know so
it's kind of like it's kind of like um a
house plant family tree type thing where
he's got a lot of them sitting around
not just one he's got a lot of trees
yeah and he's like you know and then
someone's like well those aren't even in
the same like family and he's like ah no
it's I mean look here and he like rips a
leaf off one and tapes it to the plants
and they go super part of the same one
yeah Santa's the one who you know uh is
still and the crazy thing is like these
tweets come out and they expose George
Santos as the fraud that he is and
George Santos has not deleted any one of
them so there's the one where he admits
he's like someone's like well how how
would you know about this he goes I'm
biracial
and you're like and again that's that's
probably where he is related
probably Dr Martin Luther King in that
lie in that why I mean right right right
because we talked about this before like
and I think George Han let me pull this
up this morning he tweeted something
and I thought it was um I thought it was
worth responding to and I I like George
um but I think it was like yeah I mean
obviously no [ __ ] Sherlock
um but this is an article
about George Santos telling another line
and George Hahn says it's amazing that
this [ __ ] digs his heels in claims he
was fairly elected conveniently
admitting the fact that his constituents
voted for a man with characteristics
integrity and a resume that he does not
have in other words he's a dirty liar
and I'm like he's just a republican
typical like what what [ __ ]
Republican hasn't [ __ ] duped their
constituents into believing stuff that
they are not rather about a resume or
their characteristics I mean Jesus
Christ Donald Trump himself is not that
tall he's not that orange his hair is
not that color he does not have that
much hair he is not that thin that suit
is tailored and he is wearing a girdle
he shits his pants not in the toilet I
mean these are things that they lie
about all the time these are all lies
yeah it's uh
I
the thing about George Santos is
even
like Republicans have the ability to lie
sure right and some of them are pretty
good at it and they're pretty creative
and they know how to you know politick
the game around and you know and move
around but
the idea that George Santos just like
disregards it's almost like he's trying
he's like you know what line I'm gonna
reinvent the wheel here I'm gonna show
you guys how I can make it cool and I'm
going to show you my version everyone's
like no dude you just gotta you just
gotta lie when you lie you just gotta
like have some truth to it or you just
gotta make sure that if someone's gonna
look into it it's gonna take a real hard
time to find it but when he goes in and
he says oh uh I'm biracial my mother or
my grandparents survived the Holocaust
which they didn't I was a star
volleyball of Baruch College team and I
took them to the championship he didn't
uh I worked for a Citigroup in in
Goldman Sachs he didn't
um
he said he was one of the first cases in
New York to have covid he wasn't like
there are so many things
but that's the thing even in this quote
here because this is a guardian article
this is the one that uh George had
tweeted here and the headline is and and
this is a a quote from
um the the America First Nazi Matt Getz
right it really it really was something
to watch them on the same podcast right
you wanted anything pretty much yeah
it's only like seven and a half minutes
of them talking but but you watch the
whole thing for your what was that yeah
yeah it's pretty funny so so here's the
quote
from Matt Getz
George Santos deserves a chance to make
a case right now here's the thing
I've been saying this
for weeks now that he's not any kind of
outlier as a republican he just in he
likes all the Republican lines so he
tells all of them again normally with
normal typical average Republicans
they'll pick out three or four lies
sometimes six or eight [ __ ] boxes like
Matt gatz make it up to 12 or 15 of
these lies at any given time
uh Marjorie Taylor green bobert you know
these These are really [ __ ] horrible
bio human beings but George Santos is
like why stop at 15. why it's not there
why stop it two dozen why stop it three
dozen why not tell every lie you
possibly can tell and commit crime along
the way why not you know what this
actually reminds me of has anyone uh
well we'll see in the comments have you
seen the the remake of The Italian Job
the one that was made in the early 2000s
yeah it's got uh it's got Mos Def and
it's got uh Mark Wahlberg and it's got
right yep I have seen it down Sutherland
okay all right so that's a remake for
anyone who doesn't know the original
one's good
um kind of legit a cliffhanger not to
ruin the end but uh but the Remake
there's in the in the beginning sequence
right which I'm not ruining in here this
is literally the plot of the movie
Edward Norton is the bad guy in the
movie okay
and they have just successfully pulled
off this Heist they stole these gold
bars they're sitting on a bridge or on a
out in the the Alps or whatever and
um they're all drinking champagne and
they're talking about what they're going
to take right or like what they're gonna
buy with their gold right and you know
um they're talking about buying cars
buying homes buying this you know a
speaker system all this stuff right
Edward Norton says
because they're like oh what are you
gonna do because yeah that all sounds
pretty good
and they're like what do you mean he
goes yeah I mean I'll take each one of
those ideas
and what he was obviously foreshadowing
was he was going to steal the gold and
backstab them and then right that was
that was the setup for the movie but
that is what reminds me George Santos is
Edward Norton in that movie and he also
gets taken down obviously at the end uh
but Edward Norton in that movie was like
yeah you know what I'm not creative I
can't come up with this on my own like
on my own kind of idea
and then says yeah I'll just take each
one of those like it's a [ __ ] a la
carte buffet and you're like yeah I'll
take some of those and some of those and
some of those and they're like oh
there's a limit sir and he goes what
look there my whole family's behind me
and then he just puts on a wig and a
mustache and a hat and the glasses and
he's like look look at all these people
and they're like sir you just put on all
those items it goes yeah yeah but it's
it's for my family uh it's it's the
whole Buffet I'll take whatever I want
right so this is that why Buffet he's at
the library yeah he's he's at a live but
he's overeating and they tell you right
they're like oh you're gonna you know
you can always come back for more plates
or whatever you gotta limit this
whatever he's like no no I'm gonna do
whatever I want I'm gonna take how much
ever I want I'm gonna
uh uh I'm going and you know especially
with buffets like no you can't the whole
the whole purpose is like eat as much as
you can in that sitting you cannot take
leftovers and George Sanders like no I'm
gonna take as many leftovers I can he's
like dumping into his backpack that he
carries the capital every day and
stuffing it into his fake glasses in his
case George Santos really is the person
who is not creative who is not good at
coming up with lies and just takes other
people's lives and then doesn't even
modify them or doesn't have any sort of
like oh well at least I can excuse this
because it was like so creative or so
unique or whatever it was Santos just
doesn't do that he just picks it out and
goes yeah but I'll just take it stock
off the shelf
well I mean again
I know he tells a lot of lies and that's
what kind of makes him significant but
these this is not this is not uh
abnormal now one of our favorite
seems to be parody accounts possible
Santa or Nick Adams Nick Adams oh my God
which by the way Nick Adams his real
name if anyone doesn't know this wait
he's got a fake name too huh his real
name is Nicholas
I think it's Randolph
Randolph hold on hold on hold on
Nicholas I just want to make sure I
thought it was a Greek it is it is it's
on there's a full name he's got a middle
name in here oh okay
Randall Randolph mm-hmm
hold on sorry sorry
geez Louise the guy doesn't have his
research in hand while you're pulling
that up I'm gonna I'm gonna show you
this his MLK day it's [ __ ] Ronald
Nicholas Ronald
adamopolis wow okay not Nick Adams
Nicholas Ronald adamopoulos adamopoulos
I I don't know why like if you're an
alpha own it dude if that's your name
own it don't change your name well I
mean I thought his last name I thought
his last name was alpha male now that's
his middle name oh he changed his name
from Nicholas Ronald adamopolis to Nick
alpha or Alfalfa male as some people
call them atoms
so you're gonna tell me that the guy
who changed his name because he didn't
like it because he wasn't Alpha enough
to own it and dig in had to change it
because he was insecure you're telling
me that's the same guy that goes outside
of us of an m m store buys a pack of M
M's tells you to buy a pack of M M's so
that you can stomp on them just yeah
really own them limbs own that
are buying like M M's we don't really
care what you do with it you just paid
us money you do whatever you you could
put him up your butt if you want yeah
maybe Nick Adams you don't give him too
many ideas but this is his and now I'm
going to show you a couple posts from
this chucklehead
I don't know why but this [ __ ] idiot
has been showing up in my feed the same
way we're going to talk about some of
this anti-vac stuff has been showing up
in my feet I told you over this this
over the weekend and and I want to point
it out today to people uh what's going
on on Twitter and how they're using
[ __ ] old videos to try to press their
propaganda on the country because
they're trying to convince someone that
the government is killing them which
it's not the government dealing them
it's your bone-headed ideas that are
killing you these unvaccinated people
are dying big time I don't know if
anyone realizes but this variant is
[ __ ] killing non-vaccinated people
like a [ __ ] and getting them
sick and hospitalizing them
um but Nick Adams here
he says today we honor a great
Republican
and a civil rights odd guy notice notice
Republicans first here with the
intention right now the grossest part
about this I think is how he [ __ ]
Brands this picture
a Martin Luther King with his [ __ ]
name with well his his pseudonym as we
should call it also I'm pretty sure that
that looks like a
that logo looks familiar but I'll come
back to in a second anyway
but how [ __ ] disgusting is that he
can't just post a picture of MLK Day
he has to Brand his own [ __ ] name on
it
I mean I mean you know like the
thumbnail
for our show we don't put the show name
on it I don't put my name on it we just
do a thumbnail for you to look at
YouTube right to see kind of what the
show's about that day but don't you know
that MLK
Jr like today is the day when
Republicans take some quote that Martin
Luther King said oh we're gonna find a
bunch I want to find Miss Minnie of the
[ __ ] bad things misappropriate and
then say you know if MLK was alive today
and then some push some [ __ ] dumb
narrative
that goes against uh what he actually
stood for and what he actually fought
for and what he actually believed in
and then of course
when you've got his family that's like
nope actually he would have never done
that and he would have never said that
and I would know because I'm his next of
kin or I'm you know blood relative or I
was in the house with him or whatever it
might be right
and then of course you know Republicans
they don't ever want to respond to it
even though when they're called out by
literal family members from the literal
tree not a George Santos family tree but
an actual family tree
these are the people is Republicans want
to they wanna
reclaim or reappropriate or I guess I
just appropriate his quotes in his
standing in his kind of beliefs for
their own to say oh well this is this is
what he meant when he was talking he was
talking about Democrats he was talking
about these these Democrats who are
trying to push these liberal socialist
agendas and it's like I don't know what
I mean I mean I I had the title today
because it's I I'm we've been trying to
figure out what the hell they mean by
woke yeah here for months because they
kind of moved the goal post and you know
what woke means and I was thinking about
this morning as I was working out
and I listened to the clip
um from the Birmingham Jail someone
posted the uh the audio uh from the
letter of the Birmingham Jail where
Martin Luther King Jr is actually
reading the letter and I was like he is
the father of woke if you really go back
and you look at it I mean he's the
father of wokeism I mean modern wokism
is Dr Martin Luther King Jr if that's
what they're against and and the
Birmingham uh the letter from the
Birmingham Jail really spells it out and
and because Martin Luther King basically
says hey it's moderate white people
who are more of a danger to to blacks in
America
then then the actual racist because the
races are avert you know your enemy you
know what they believe
but this idea that you're going to
tolerate intolerance and just stand back
and be part of the perpetuation of it is
way more dangerous because you're the
ones that could speak up you're the ones
that could in a resounding voice say no
we're not going to tolerate your [ __ ]
racism your [ __ ] bigotry your goddamn
nationalism we're not going to do it
we're just not going to have it here and
if we all said that especially moderate
white Republicans
not liberals not people who will speak
out like me but moderates people who
will say it in one resounding voice
um it would it would it would wake
if you can use that word wake up the
country right
um I believe that's what we saw in 2020
and when people watched on the Internet
is uh Derek Chauvin the murderer the
murderer snuffed out the Life of George
Floyd with his knee on his neck and on a
video on the internet watched him murder
him and had no absolutely no remorse and
no compassion for his his life in that
moment
and I think the country woke up to that
and they marched in the streets just
like Martin Luther King Jr would have
done they spoke out
against the brutality of black people
just like Martin Luther King Jr would
have done
um I'm looking at Marjorie Taylor
Green's page she hasn't done a shitty
post yet
uh well I'm just looking at a rep page I
figured that's where it was going to be
um what about Jim Jordan is this
[ __ ] posting any kind of vile
[ __ ] yet I'm sure Jim Jordan we can
expect Jim Jones MLK you know that's
probably what he says well gas stoves
first yeah I don't guess those are
definitely over there yes of course he
did okay let's
retweeted a video by representative
Wesley Hunt's press office which says as
the leader of the Civil Rights Movement
Martin Luther King Jr traversing uh the
nation in his quest for equality and
lost his life fighting for the principle
that each of us be judged by the content
of our character instead of the color of
our skin again I I told you in the
beginning 30 minutes audience that they
would talk about content to character
and I have a dream that's the one they
go to and they're like he's a republican
civil rights wink
um and and all the while I don't know if
you know this Gabe Sanchez and I talked
about my experience because I don't have
have an experience as a person of color
in this country
I don't my experience is Rule white that
is my experience that is where I that is
the the experience that I can draw from
I I do not I the only thing I can do is
to listen to people of color and to hear
their experience that is the only thing
derive my opinions based on their
experience because I don't have that
experience I will never have the
experience of a person of color and a
lot of people don't even know that right
now today there are white rural schools
that intentionally are having school
today on this federal holiday the only
federal holiday where they will have
school by the way by the way and their
excuses well I mean wouldn't it be
offensive if we let white people out of
school on on the black day that's
literally what they'll say or they'll
say wow we don't have any black people
in our schools or why would we let out
no one will get offended and they don't
understand the underlying reason why we
have a Federal holiday not just not just
remembering the man
but why he did and what he did what he
did and I used to understand it I I
wouldn't I wouldn't be surprised if the
only reason that Republicans acknowledge
Martin Luther King today is because they
have the day off because it's a you know
a Federal holiday because they're
they're forced to right you know they're
like oh my constituents have the day off
I might as well acknowledge it right
but the idea that Republicans can just
claim right they're like we stand for
the same values we don't want to be
persecuted I mean keep in mind these are
the same people that tried to compare
the Holocaust
to vaccine status right getting the
vaccine was like where in the Star of
David during warlord during the
Holocaust like
these people are the ones who are going
to appropriate someone else's oppression
okay that is what Republicans do they
say oh whoa I'm not being no I'm not
being oppressed I am not being oppressed
right now so I have to take someone
else's oppression and claim it for my
own so that I can relate and so then
what they'll do is they'll come up with
sun like Manila colored version of their
own problems like a first world problem
but only for white people
and say oh the persecution the
persecution
and turns out it's like no it's actually
by choice it's not because someone else
took it against you it's because you
took it against yourself and then tried
to claim it's like it's like that uh
it's like that cartoon where you see the
person riding the bike and they stick
this they put the stick in in the spoke
and they trip on the ground and they're
holding their knee and then they blame
someone else for it that's exactly what
Republicans are doing and they do it for
Martin Luther King Jr day they do it for
uh vaccine status they do it for you
know anything else where someone else is
being oppressed or someone else is going
through
the hardships of having you know the
color of their skin right the first
judgment that has passed is this person
is dangerous because their skin color is
darker than mine right and we see with
police we see it with politicians we see
with people walking down the street
there is unbiased or there's a
subconscious or conscious or conscious
um
uh
uh judgment that is happening from one
person to another and Republicans are
going to on today of all days of course
are going to take this well we also are
people of of travesty and judgment and
hardship and persecution and oppression
because they don't want the narrative to
be about someone else they don't want
they don't like the idea that the
narrative is about someone who isn't
white right and they have to make it
about them you know it's like I'm gonna
let you finish but like that's exactly
what this moment is right now and any
other time you see a holiday or or
someone of a you know different skin
color or minority group marginalized
Community they're going to take credit
they're going to put it on themselves
and try to say that they are the
actually they're the victims they're the
ones who are being uh persecuted and
being judged but they're not they're the
ones who just do it to themselves and
they claim claim that they are
I
I want to show you a video because as
we're talking about them appropriating
um
the
the I Have a Dream speech and really
using those two those two phrases I have
a dream and content of your character
you know they love those those are the
ones that have been institutionalized in
even right white Rural America really
sanitizing
sanitizing the legacy of Dr Martin
Luther King Jr I'm dead serious I had no
idea about the letter from the
Birmingham Jail when I was a kid the
only thing we knew was I have a dream
content of your character right
that's what we that's what we were
that's the washing the white washing of
even Martin Luther King Jr
um as as they would talk about him one
day a year while we were at school
because we didn't recognize the federal
holiday
but this is a recording
Martin Luther King Jr reading
letter from the Birmingham Jail I think
it is most important on today like today
these are the quotes this
is the context of his character
first I'm most must confess
that over the past few years I have been
Gravely disappointed
with the white moderate
I have almost reached the regrettable
conclusion
that the Negroes great stumbling block
in his stride toward freedom is not the
White Citizens counselor
of the Ku Klux klaner but the white
moderate who is more devoted to order
than to Justice
who prefers a negative peace which is
the absence of tension
to a positive piece which is the
presence of Justice
who constantly says I agree with you and
the goal you seek but I cannot agree
with your methods of direct action
who paternalistically believes he can
set the timetable for another man's
freedom
who lives by mythical concept of time
and who constantly advises the Negro to
wait for a more convenient season
shall our understanding from people of
good will
is more frustrating than absolute
misunderstanding from people of ill will
lukewarm acceptance is much more
bewildering than outright rejection
I had hoped that the white moderate
would understand
that Law and Order exists for the
purpose of establishing Justice
and that when they fail in this purpose
they become the dangerously structured
dams that blocked the Florida Social
progress
I had hoped that white moderates would
understand that the present tension in
the south
is a necessary phase of the transition
from an obnoxious negative peace in
which the Negro passively accepted his
unjust plight to a substantive and
positive peace in which all men will
respect the dignity and worth of human
personality
so there you have a segment of the
letter from the Birmingham Jail from Dr
Martin Luther King I think those quotes
Gabe Sanchez
um describe what the Republicans want to
call wokism very well
um I I think I think when you consider
yourself woke which I mean it's kind of
ridiculous that we have to do these
stupid things where we dance around
their words right but if we have to
consider ourselves woke which I just
consider it liberal
honestly you just go look up the goddamn
word liberal and and and know what it
means to accept the dignity and decency
and Liberty of all human people no
matter their color their Creed their
religion their background their
disability their ability whatever it may
be
um
and let's just I mean like let's also
remember that woke is a is a bit of a
dog uh whistle here right and that it's
connected with black lives matter it's
connected with
with the idea you know critical race
Theory right they're woke like when you
think of this then you know it's it's
the Republican Party trying to cover up
a
a systemic
racist like they're trying to cover up
systemic racism right we even see it in
Florida where a judge
asked
DeSantis general counsel
can you define woke right now Jared
saying uh
sorry George Santos uh Ron DeSantis
sometimes I like to call him George
DeSantis but it's not actually that well
uh he's kind of it's pretty close it is
but but in in Florida right you've got
Ron DeSantis right uh Trump version uh
2.0
saying Florida is where woke goes to die
I mean that's just a weird thing to say
all together but I mean you know
considering
Florida's history and what they stand
for I mean if we sub one word for
another it seems pretty on par but the
thing is in court the judge said hey
Define what you mean by woke
and his general counsel Ryan Newman had
to say right woke is the belief that
there are systemic Injustice in American
society and the need to address them
okay and and their their war is on
wokeism right by the way so their War
they're saying where woke goes to die
where the fight against systemic
injustices goes to die that tells you
everything you need to know and here is
here is Ron DeSantis himself on his
official page as Governor
um just hours ago again I I'm telling
you I I didn't even have to guess this
I'm just looking this up right now as
you said Ron DeSantis name I know
exactly what quote he's going to quote
Yeah I know which one happy MLK day he
says and he gives the sanitized quote of
Dr King because they can't they can't
admit they cannot admit that equality
and Equity is their enemy and democracy
is their enemy they cannot admit it if
they admit it they will die their party
will die their ideology will die out on
the limb so what they have to do is they
have to sanitize and use Martin Luther
King as their cudulent as their wedge
for racism and bigotry
and this is the perfect example now most
people say Tony Jesus Christ are you
saying that bigoted white nationalist
politicians posting I have a dream quote
from Dr Martin Luther King is racist and
and is and is used in a raises way yes
that is what I'm saying that is exactly
what I'm saying and if you did not grow
up in real White America if you did not
you have no clue of the experience that
I'm telling you about because Gabe
Sanchez I want to know
you you have a different experience than
me a different American Experience you
grew up in a larger populated area
you're you're half of your heritage is
Hispanic your dad's from Mexico you have
a different experience than I have a
completely just like every audience
member has a different experience than
you have and then I have that is the
beauty of our country that is the beauty
and that is what Rhonda Santos does not
want he does not want anyone to admire
any experience but his own white
privileged experience Because he
believes that if you take away
from his rich
White Privilege experience then someone
else is gaining something and he's
losing something it's ridiculous but
that is what that is the message
dripping off of this and and that's what
they don't want right I mean you know
they call America The Melting Pot right
where everyone comes from other
countries God forbid people want to you
know pursue a better life and achieve
the American dream which is a you know
obviously a dream in itself speaking of
Dreams uh especially you know in
specifically dreams when it comes to
this American Dream because Republicans
make it so hard to achieve right I think
it was uh George Carlin didn't he say
that wasn't he the one that said that
like the American dream is one like you
just keep dreaming because you can never
achieve it
yeah no no he said several he got
several bits about that right but the
idea here is that Republicans will do
whatever they can
to
to make sure that the group that already
has a hard time making it right the
group that was promised and given you
know
quote unquote equal opportunity right
uh the pursuit of happiness and Liberty
and
uh in this in the land of the free like
these are all things that we have that
we've said right and and that we say
that we stand by and some of us do right
but Republicans go against that right
they're the people that are willing to
bust migrants from another country up to
VP Harris's home on Christmas in the
freezing cold they're the people that
use others as political pawns and then
try to say ah see this is the point that
I'm trying to make which is the complete
opposite they're the people that vote
against
you know they vote against the John
Lewis voting rights of 20 Act of 2022
they're the people that vote against the
George Floyd Justice and policing act
they're the people that quote Martin
Luther Martin Luther King in the same
[ __ ] breath
and then talk about these injustices you
know
and they and they want to push the idea
again that they're the oppressed ones
that nobody has it harder than white
people
that nobody has it than white
Republicans nobody has it harder than
straight white Republicans in America
these are the things that they push even
on today they'll somehow make it about
themselves I guarantee it you'll see a
quote then you'll see someone else
challenge that quote and they go whoa
what are you what are you doing I'm
trying to push forward the values and
ideas
that Martin Luther King Jr brought to us
right they'll make it about them it like
it's a it's a complete setup you know
obviously if they ever do try to come
back in an argument when you say you
don't stand for any of these things
you're quoting a person just for the
sake of quoting you're trying to save
face right now and when you get called
out for it then they say oh whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa you're racist
because you said that I don't actually
like that's the table that they're going
to turn on this and that's the game
they're going to play because here look
on today of today of all days don't play
[ __ ] stupid games with [ __ ] dumb
Republicans who try to misuse misquote
and misappropriate Martin Luther King Jr
and the things that he said and the
things that he stood for because they're
going to do it and we see it them doing
it right now they're like oh here's a
little infographic about Martin Luther
King Jr here's a quote and you notice
how they only quote the same part right
they they always quote certain sections
that cherry pick to support their own
narrative right that says oh well
actually if Martin Luther King Jr was
around okay he would not support you
know liberals or Democrats or or
leftists or socialists that's what they
think that's what they want you know
what's funny about that
is that Martin Luther King
uh in his in his uh last few years on
this Earth
he actually went to see at president of
the United States do you know what party
the president of the United States was
does it start with a D
it might okay it might start with the
and if he truly is a republican in his
ideology which
um you know a lot of people claim that
Martin Luther King was a republican
whatever and he's not he would not be
welcome in the modern Republican party
as woke as he is today now that that
clip we played from the Birmingham Jail
Rhonda santis Rhonda santis would call
for him to be canceled
um well they would say they would say
boycotted right we got him boycott him
it's like that sounds a lot like
cancellation as if as if Martin Luther
King had any other product other than
decency
um to deliver but he worked with a
Democratic president
and LBJ who in his own right was
probably
um just as instituted in racism as any
other white person from rural Texas now
buddy but but LBJ understood something
about civil rights and that it was
untenable not to deliver civil rights
for blacks in America and that is the
most important thing is that yeah he's a
republican okay sure you're gonna start
with he's a Republican and then he's a
civil rights activist but you're failing
to miss his entire message and I'm
telling you I know I know it sounds
crass that his most famous speech I Have
a Dream and uh I forget the exact number
and I know Bernie Sanders was there
there was John Lewis was there there's a
lot of famous people and that are still
alive today that were there at that
speech and how that marched with him
right and that that important that
important moment in history but that's
why they do it that's why they take that
one speech and a few lines from it to
sanitize to sanitize the entire message
and the entire push to undo the
institutional racism in this country
that Martin Luther King so marched for
and and and it frustrates the hell out
of me because when I was a kid I was
like yeah Martin Luther King he was he
was great he marched and uh black people
got the right to vote that's that's
great and they had a dream and he had
dream and they fulfilled it they got the
right to vote he fulfilled his dream
right no no you're completely sanitizing
and missing the entire message and
that's what woke is so if if woke is
Martin Luther King count me the [ __ ] in
okay but that's what it is if the
Birmingham uh letter from the jail the
Birmingham Jail
as wokism count me the [ __ ] in I am not
gonna stand back and tolerate
intolerance we should not do it as a
society together
and I think that's um very important and
that's what you know [ __ ] boxes like Ron
desantis's little today today really
does show Republicans for the Hypocrites
that they are right the same people
that will like Lauren bobert that will
stand up during the state of the union
and say those 13 lives are on your hands
right
to which Joe Biden says you know my son
was one of the people that were victims
of the burn pits right the burn pits
that you want to call out right now and
when given the opportunity two days
later or three days later to have a vote
on the house floor to say hey let's
let's fund veteran health care for those
who are impacted and how and have have
issues from from exposure to burn pits
and Republicans say no no right and when
given the chance to to fund other things
that they stand up and say hey we should
have these things they'll vote against
it in the same way like I brought up
against George Floyd George Floyd's
policing act against the the uh John
Lewis voting rights act like all of
these things
Republicans are 100
Hypocrites who do not actually stand for
American values or let alone Christian
values to care for another fellow human
being they'll bust people across the
country they'll lie about this they'll
persecute them they'll do this they'll
you know turn a blind eye when someone
actually receives harassment based on
the color of their skin
and then today
they want to quote I have a dream they
want to say oh this character oh he's
got a national holiday yeah well here's
Christopher Webb and he makes a great
point because it's a point you were just
making
if they want to appropriate the the
legacy of Martin Luther King into their
Republican party and he says Christopher
says they may quote him today but
remember Republicans fought hard against
making Martin Luther King Day a holiday
before they celebrate him after years of
public pressure now this is a quote from
Ronald Reagan back in 1983. it says I
would have preferred a non-holiday in
King's honor but since they seem bent on
making it a national holiday they I'm
sure he means a certain
demographic of people certain day that
might be in the photo right there right
um making a national holiday I believe
the symbolism of that day is important
enough and I will sign that legislation
when it reaches my death so you know
what I really don't want to yeah but I
have to not to appear racist this is the
same thing this quote from President
Ronald Reagan October 20th 1983 is the
same thing as Ron DeSantis posting
the same exact thing is Rhonda Santos
posting
an MLK quote on his [ __ ] Governor's
page today saying happy MLK I don't want
to post this I really I know
King
the father of wokeism but I have to
placate and I have to you know since
they're bent on you know holding me
accountable and I gotta pretend that I
like you know Martin Luther King just as
much as I like veterans and any other
disabled Americans children women you
know I have to pretend so I'm gonna post
this thing just like Ronald Reagan
pretended he wanted it to be a national
holiday as he signed it uh in this
picture here and they they are like you
said they are there yeah watching him
sign their hell-bent need to commemorate
I mean it kind of is a beautiful photo
because you have this group of people
right
who are looking down like I mean you
know if you take it back like in this
you have a let's say the president the
master right you've got people from the
African-American Community these these
black people right here who are
representing their community
right his family others within others
who are from that Civil Rights Movement
being like this is a great moment now
you may not want to sign this but we're
gonna [ __ ] make you sign this and I
believe this photo
is a nice kind of representation
of these people looking down on
President Reagan right looking down on
him as they make him sign this thing
despite his um reluctance we'll say
because they want to have a national
holiday right he'd rather give them a
non-holiday well Jesus Christ man
like there are holiday oh my God okay do
you know what do you know why do you
know why Ronald Reagan didn't want this
to be a national holiday
why the exact reason why I said earlier
rural white schools did not want to let
out on this national holiday
they do they don't want the CRT it's
it's that day and age is CRT because if
you have to commemorate in real White
America
Dr Martin Luther King Jr oh my God you
will offend a lot of white but white
people will feel really guilty and
really bad about the things that their
parents are doing
and and the views that their parents
held on segregation and voting rights
and civil rights in general I mean God
forbid we allow the Next Generation to
be better than the previous right isn't
that the whole goal in America well
don't get all right don't get all woke
on us here again I'm just saying isn't
that what they say that well let me ask
you let me ask life for the ones that
follow because you do have a different
experience than I do and I talked about
my experience with MLK day and growing
up in rural White America what what do
you remember as a school-aged child
learning about Martin Luther King and
learning about what the day meant and
commemorating him and remembering him
what did you remember things
um from from uh when you were introduced
to because because we're not old enough
to know who Dr King was in real life we
was he was I mean I was assassinated
along before we were born the most
experienced so as a kid so I went to I
went to public school my uh for the
first year and then I got in a lot of
trouble fights and stuff like that and
then was sent to you yeah yeah and then
I was sent to Catholic uh Grade School
uh as a means of You Hell getting my act
together we'll say uh those nuns had to
whip you into shape yeah yeah well we
actually didn't have another actually
yeah no we didn't know we had we had
priests but uh yeah well maybe even
worse
but my my experience was we had
uh let's say here I'll just put it this
way I learned more about Martin Luther
King Jr outside of the classroom than I
did inside the classroom right uh there
were obviously I I feel like I learned
more as a
in the younger grades because they're
always like Hey we're going to work on
this class presentation or we're going
to work on this you know activity or
this like arts and crafts things I felt
like as a kid there was more learning
that happened when I was younger
in a class group setting than I did when
I was older in in grade school
um and then when I went to high school
obviously you know it was I went to a
public high school and from there was
like Hey we're gonna teach you about
everything right and some of the things
I knew and some things I didn't across
all things right
um but when I was younger I felt like oh
we're gonna do this you know we're gonna
do something to commemorate Martin
Luther King Jr we're going to do this
you know arts and crafts kind of project
we're going to say we're gonna do a
class presentation in front of the
school we're gonna whatever it might be
right
uh and I felt those ways especially
because I would like have to do kind of
a little re you know reading and
research outside of school and I would
learn things from my parents and I would
learn things about him and what he stood
for and you know Birmingham and
you know dogs hosing jail like all you
know the the sit-ins like all of these
things I learned actually outside of the
classroom but in some ways there was a
little bit of a classroom kind of like
spark that Lit it to be like oh we're
gonna do this class presentation this
class project or whatever
and then
my curiosity would take me Beyond those
things because they're all connected
right it's not just one isolated event
it's all of these dominoes that are
falling and all of these things that are
happening that isn't not just one it
wasn't just Rosa Parks you know not
willing to get up from her seat it
wasn't just the sit-ins at the diners it
wasn't just marches that happened here
it wasn't just Martin Luther King it
wasn't just Malcolm X like it was all of
these things that came together but my
experience personally in school as I
grew up
was
not so educational like I said I learned
more than I did when I was outside of
the classroom in my own home or with
other people within my community or my
friends that you know lived in my part
of the neighborhood that weren't white
right learning through their experience
exactly right and you learn about what's
going on and you know you'll you know
listen to speeches that are on the radio
or you listen to you know different
types of music or different types of art
or culture whatever it is and it gives
you perspective to tell you during this
time the inspiration or the the
the mood of the country was this right
what inspired you know uh this artist to
make this thing well it was based on
this experience he had around this right
around civil rights around this war
around this movement or whatever it is
um and of course you've and right now
like I and I'll say this like as someone
who is
Hispanic and white right like on some
days when I was younger I'd get you know
judgment for my last name or the way I
said something or the color of my skin
or whatever it might be and other days I
would pass
and nothing would be a problem right
even within my own Community like within
the Hispanic Latino Community there is
there is a ton of internal racism of
you're not enough of this and you're not
enough of that or you're too much of
that or you're too much of this
um and obviously that's something within
the black community as well right yeah
well we watched that happen to Barack
Obama when you ran for president right
out in the open
um you know he was either not wine
enough not black enough I mean and these
are the types of um these are types of
institutionalized
um in our society stuff and I want to
play this
um this is um Reverend Dr Barber
and uh Tennessee holler is is uh posted
this is a flashback the quote is
politicians can't say they love Dr King
but then refuse to support his agenda
right governor and this is a time that
uh Dr Barber uh Reverend Dr Barber
called out Governor Bill Lee and to his
face
um and this has got to be a great video
so a couple minutes long let's take a
listen to Dr Reverend Dr Barber so
politicians can't say they love Dr King
and how he stood for love and unity
but then you deny refuse to support his
agenda
right governor
[Applause]
I mean since you since you came
right congressman
so let me show you what I mean governor
Dr King
would not have been for a wall
[Music]
and the hurting how many of y'all are
not against the wall
everybody here is not against the wall
politicians everybody and we'll tell
Donald Trump you don't need to be
building a wall to separate people we
need to be spending money to give people
Health Care stand on eBay
now everybody doesn't stand on your feet
you get to see
[Music]
wait a minute
how many folk in here believe like Dr
King that everybody
ought to have what Teddy Roosevelt a
Republican asked for a hundred years ago
and that's your health care for every
citizen everybody believes that stand up
now if you can't stand up for that then
don't say you love Dr King
oh
my God
you may be seated
I'm just saying I'm too old to play now
you may be seated
preachers
don't just think I'm talking to
politicians just cause you can talk
about it from the poor bit but then you
are you I'm gonna say it like I feel it
can find you for your pastor's
anniversary but they can't find you in
the street with these students and these
other folks fighting for Injustice
if you are a preacher of the gospel and
you are asking your people to tithe but
you are not fighting for them to have a
living way you are lying
ah there you go ah fire I mean it it is
I mean it was one of those things man if
you're if you're a politician and you I
mean walking in we'll say this walking
into
um a church or you know wherever your
your community might be
and you're not a hundred percent on with
the things that you say politician you
like getting called out like that with a
bunch of people being like look Stan if
you do this stay City if you stay seated
if you if you don't you said you came
you came here yeah you walked into right
this dog fight that we have where you
you walked into the on you said you
support you say you love him but do you
said it show us and so I think I think
it's you know moments like that are
great because obviously you know it does
it you obviously you know you can you
can assume based on the reaction that
they did not stand right or if they did
stand they did so reluctantly just like
uh Ronald Reagan right so the idea that
these again these Republicans want to
say oh we stand for these rights we
stand for these injustices we stand if
you really did if you really [ __ ] did
then you would have no problem voting
for you know equality Health Care
education
higher wages right instead you guys want
to [ __ ] about Goods gun God Guns babies
gas stoves [ __ ] grocery prices uh you
want to [ __ ] and moan about how Donald
Trump is being falsely persecuted for
actually stealing documents you want oh
which I wanna I wanna get to at some
point I want to get to that at some
point I also want to get to this
anti-vac stuff on it's always it's
always always always always going to be
this moment of whoa whoa whoa hold on
let's as a as a white person they it's
almost like a uh white people
Republicans want to play this like
oppression Olympics right against
against Hispanics black people Asians
whoever my you know the Jewish Community
whoever they might be they want to play
the book no we had it worse it's like
your people literally came in and took
over fought us made us change into
believing your religion made us speak
English like all of these things across
the country you can't tell me that white
people have had it for hard okay you
can't tell me that when you literally
look at most if not all the problems
that exist in the world are based on
white people religion uh uh you know War
violence whatever these are people that
do not believe in the things that Martin
Luther King Jr believed well you these
one of these people don't they believe
in the opposite you want to know the um
the one thing that
circles the fear of white people's
privilege the most
it is the fear that if we give them as
much privilege as we have they might
treat us white people the way that we
want to treat them it's the fear of
being oppressed the way that they
oppress people of color in this country
that's what it is is the fear of that
um I don't usually do this but um here's
a clip from uh President Joe Biden
speaking of documents and maybe that'll
give us a good segue into this
um um he's making remarks um at the MLK
Day address and he talks about
um woke huh
it's funny how the word woke comes up
when you're talking about Martin Luther
King once listen
[Applause]
the idea if you can hold a second here
the idea
that we're supposed to remain silent on
the on on abuses of the past
as they didn't as if they didn't occur
that's not being woke that's being
honest
that's talking about history
and so there's uh President Joe Biden
and a small clip about awokism and how
acknowledging the past just to just
simply acknowledging
in the past
um on civil rights and our indiscretions
towards people of color in this country
on civil rights is is a bad thing and
somehow that's evil and it's gonna hurt
you and somehow it's going to destroy
who we are as a country to know who we
are as a country it's [ __ ] ridiculous
but but don't you I mean like you got to
understand that acknowledging a problem
is a problem for Republicans right right
if because they're like well out of
sight out of mind if I don't got to
think about it it never happened right
if I don't got to think about slavery if
I don't got to think about these other
things that are within the critical race
well that's the whole that's the whole I
don't want people to get married because
they're gay if people can't get married
and openly say they're gay then it goes
away then they're I don't have to fear
being gay myself or having no feelings
they know what they do is wrong because
they try to hide the things that make
them feel bad right they don't want to
acknowledge oh yeah yeah we did have a
problem I mean we still do have a
problem but we had a problem during this
time for various different events that
happened but if we don't talk about them
then they never did they really it's
like the whole like if a fall trees in a
forest and no one's around to hear it
did it really fall kind of thing and
they like to push that same idea where
they say well if we don't talk about
this event if we don't talk about the
travesty of the Trail of Tears right if
we don't talk about the Civil Rights
Movement if we don't talk about uh uh
you know the genocide of indigenous
people in this country both from those
who were in The Northern America and
Southern America or Middle America
portion of this country or this this
continent then did it ever really happen
right didn't didn't Ronda Santa say that
the land wasn't stolen he said that in a
debate with uh not only that I saw I
forgot what I was watching I was
watching another video the other day and
somebody was getting called out for and
they're like the land wasn't stolen oh
actually you know what there was a clip
it was a Doctor Phil there's a local
there's a guy in La who's a who's a a
civil rights activist and
um he went on Dr Phil and there was a
there was a border patrol and someone
else they're talking about [ __ ]
about how you know all of these uh
migrants or illegals are coming across
the border all this [ __ ] and stuff
like that right but keep in mind we have
a [ __ ] open border with Canada okay
we have an open border with Canada you
can drive game Sanchez the majority of
those people are white okay and they
speak English but uh and friends on the
doctor on the Dr Phil and I put in quote
Dr Phil Show yeah
they were talking you know these white
guys were talking about this and they're
saying this whatever and he spoke out he
was I think he was in the back and he
spoke out and they're like what would
you say and he went back and forth and
he talked about
[Music]
um
the position and he says you know
the problems aren't from you know
Hispanic people coming across the border
that's not where these people are coming
from right you got people from taking a
trip in from Europe staying over you got
people coming in from Canada staying
over these people who are you know
seeking Asylum you want to push them
away like the Christians that you are
you want to say oh no these people don't
have the same rights as us these people
don't have to you know again
do you know how many Canadians probably
live in Los Angeles that are here or
legally trying to become actors yeah
there's a ton you're right I'm here in
LA or it's going to be Toronto right
right like either those two areas
there's a ton of white Canadians that
have come to tons and to California the
Southern California become actors and
have overstayed their visas some that
are probably famous that you know of
um but they but they're white so you
don't it's not a you're right out of
sight out of mind speaking of uh no
brains
and we're going to flip to the documents
case here real quick because I want to
make sure that um people still
understand the [ __ ] differences
between these two [ __ ] cases for
crying the media the media sucks at this
so bad they're so horrible at this and
this is why Jim Jordan can do this
stupid [ __ ] on Twitter this morning he
said what prompted him to look for Joe
Biden's classified documents like this
is not this is not news Jim Jordan this
morning on January 16th you [ __ ]
you've done been told the Penn Center
wanted to have the office that Joe Biden
was using to be vacated and empties
so that they could use that space
so they were going through the lock
closets where some of this stuff was to
vacate it to move it to get it out of
their way that is what prompted them to
look at Joe Biden's stuff you [ __ ]
bonehead and as soon as they found them
they notified the authorities handed
over the documents immediately and went
through the proper chain of custody
without obstruction there was no intent
of overthrowing the government and
covering up that [ __ ] coup plot by
stealing these documents this is
ridiculous I cannot even believe that
every single time the media brings us up
they do not say these cases are
different because of two reasons the
intent of the stolen documents and the
[ __ ] obstruction it says it in the
goddamn search warrant yeah that's the
[ __ ] search warrant says it
Joe Biden can't break the presidential
records act if the intent was not there
the intent was there for trump it is
clear he's let us know that he has let
us know that by publicly making this a
goddamn circus now because this is what
Trump does but Jim Jordan Jordan here is
doing what Tucker Carlson does every
night why do we have to consider Russia
our mortal enemy can't we be friends
with Russia can't we be allies with
Putin what makes us have to hate Putin
what prompted them the look for Joe
Biden's classified documents it's not
rocket science it's not and the reason
why Merrick Garland has appointed two
special counsels one for the Joe Biden
documents case because it's a different
case than the one for the Trump document
case and the reason why the Trump
document case has the same special
counsel as the January 6th is because
that's why he stole the documents folks
that's why he's stolen it's in the
[ __ ] warrant it's in the warrant he
did not want this evidence to go it is
evidence the Joe Biden documents are not
evidence of a crime the [ __ ]
documents that Trump stole are evidence
of crimes you dumb mother why do you
think he stole them he stole him because
he wants to read him he doesn't even
know how to read you [ __ ] boneheads
and the media is pissing me off every
time so is uh Jim Jordan but I'm Gonna
Keep pounding this drum and I'm telling
you when you talk to people you tell
them the difference is
Joe Biden did not steal United States
top top secret classified documents to
cover up his attempt to have a coup and
overthrow our vote
how I don't know how more clear I have
to be than that I mean not only that but
let's also bring up the idea of just the
timeline itself okay
if we were to compare the two situations
right again we we said the way that I
said it yesterday or last week was it's
a it's apples to oranges and we all know
who the origin orange
is in the situation the orange pleather
face is the dude that spent 18 months
okay and we don't even know if we have
them all by the way okay we're
we don't even know if we have all of the
documents some of those [ __ ] folders
were missing documents right exactly so
we have 18 months from the point at
which the original inquiry happened from
Nara to say hey we got these documents
to them moving
uh line storing uh
uh St you know stealing like all of
these different phases right of them
taking the boxes putting in this room
taking the boxes putting in this area
you know them saying don't go into this
locked room now then going into the
locked room uh finding them in his desk
finding them in between uh the Time
magazine covers that he had of himself
like the guy complete ego maniacal your
egotistical guy right and you've got
this dude
who spent 18 months evading the law
right he was he was [ __ ] running from
the law in the sense of not willing he's
like no no no no no no no no taxi
backsies it's mine and like we never
even gave it to you you did not have the
privilege to own these things you as the
president were able to see them
but you don't get to keep them right
that's ours that's the American peoples
that is the governments
and so he spent 18 months trying to play
this like [ __ ] shell game of where
the documents were
Joe Biden
they went through the Penn Center
they found the documents in November
they reported it the FBI was looking
into it they found some more documents
in the garage you had a special counsel
that was assigned by Merrick Garland
within two months this was like Hey look
we found these documents and the people
that found them like oh we don't have we
don't have the clearance to look at this
we're going to notify attorney we're
going to notify the FBI we're going to
notify uh you know the special counsel
in this in as the more recent situation
happened that's the main difference here
is you've got one guy
who stole them and didn't want to give
them back and lied about it for 18
months and we don't even know if we have
them all yet
and then we've got Joe Biden where they
found the documents in November and
we've got two months later and they're
like look here are the things now I will
I will be the first to say now I think
that this is good for Democrats but I
also feel like I would not have chosen
Robert Herr as he is from the Trump doj
and the whole talk successful there but
you also know and have seen now that the
Fox News of Republicans
are not happy with that they will never
be happy with it whoever you choose
but it undermines their narrative I mean
just the simple Narrative of of
Mar-A-Lago is Trump's home he has a
private Residence at Mar-A-Lago it's
like an apartment there that place is a
[ __ ] public Club it's a club it is
much different than the [ __ ] private
residents of Joe Biden much different
much [ __ ] different just that alone
but the problem is is that no one no one
is saying out loud over and over and
over and over and over again so I'm
gonna say it it is the intent and the
obstruction that is the whole [ __ ]
difference now I will reassure you
that Jack Smith does not give two
[ __ ] shits not a [ __ ] good God
damn what documents are what the story
is behind the Joe Biden documents I will
assure you that that nail eaten son of a
[ __ ] definitely does not give two [ __ ]
about that case it is not his case it is
not the one he's Prosecuting he does not
give a [ __ ] and the fact is I keep
hearing this again and again from legal
people and all that [ __ ] on [ __ ]
cable TV somehow Merrick Garland's Gonna
Fly flat on this case of the Mar-A-Lago
documents people if you go look at the
search warrant it ain't really about the
[ __ ] documents that's why Merrick
Garland appointed Jack Smith to not just
be the special counsel for the documents
but he wrapped the January 6th it is
evidence it is [ __ ] evidence for the
January 6 coup attempt
um bottom line that is what it is that's
why Donald Trump is terrified of it
that's why they're trying to use a
couple documents appearing in in the
former vice president the current
president's records at his home and at
an office they're using that as a cudgel
and we can't let them take control of
this narrative they had a a Twitter
space with Tom Fenton yeah and who else
was in there the other night I was
listening stuff
[ __ ] [ __ ] gets in start stock and
I I left I'm like I can't stand this
[ __ ]
Reed that was in there even worse even
[ __ ] worse that lion that lion piece
of trash Tara Reid I can't I can't
understand
why why uh anyone would participate in
these these types of frauds and lies but
I guess it's good for you know numbers
and it's good to perpetuate uh your
social media account you know what
whatever you want to consider this it's
the same thing that they did with the
the Twitter files and the Andrew Tate
Story look this is clear-cut this is
clear-cut Joe Biden in the
administration
they found documents he wasn't supposed
to have him where he had them they're
trying to get to the bottom of it they
absolutely are contacting the proper
authorities to that immediately Merrick
Garland the Attorney General because of
dumb [ __ ] Republicans who are lying
about documents because to be frank with
Gabe Sanchez if the Republican lies are
true which they're not about Donald
Trump declassifying these and that's why
he's allowed to have them then Joe Biden
gets the same [ __ ] excuse he could
say
at any time when I became president
United States
when my hand left the Bible my mind in
my mind I believed that I Declassified
all those documents that were in my
office and next to my Corvette and
they're Declassified so that makes them
mine and you can't do anything about it
on the president and by the way he's the
president United States you can't
prosecute him for anything from now
until the eternity because he's immune
from everything any crime that he wants
to commit he can commit and he's immune
yeah so I mean that that is what I'm
telling you by this undermines their
narrative and we can unwind it and it's
not going to do them any good folks it
really isn't as as Jack Smith presents
his case to the American people which he
will it will show that their [ __ ]
arguments are loose lies that are built
to deceive you into thinking that Donald
Trump is not who he is just like George
Santos right you [ __ ] buffoons Donald
Trump is the original George Santos
he's the original he's the OG Santos
[ __ ] idiots man original George
Santos OG Santos the OG Santos
oh [ __ ] I just I can't yeah well you
know I mean that's describing it yes and
there's this conspiracy theory going
around on the left about the Secret
Service planting these doc people listen
shut the [ __ ] up that is not that is not
anywhere close to what happened he is
not being set up it's not a trap it's
not some [ __ ] weird-ass conspiracy
theory it is what it appears when he
packed up his office and his home as the
vice president
there were documents because
the in the executive branch they have
Skiffs sometimes right in their office
okay they're secure locations in some of
their offices their offices are Skiffs
at some point in the executive branch
these documents were inadvertently
packed up they weren't paying attention
and that is really that may be the
argument that we need to have is yeah
how do we how do we move these
Executives out in such a hurry that we
don't know that some of these some of
our secrets may be getting out there in
space as they shouldn't be because we're
trying to pack them up so quickly I mean
yeah I mean that that is a guy that was
another point I wanted to bring up is
like yeah you've got a transition that
happens from one Administration to
another
and you know when you're not trying to
fight it over you know folk Vader this
stupid [ __ ] hang on a second Don from
Facebook yeah I keep saying to skip hey
hey you stupid [ __ ] neither neither is
mar Lago neither is his death drawer
neither is melania's underwear drawer
neither is his safe you stupid
[ __ ] so if you're going if
you're seriously gonna have serious
outrage about a few documents being
found at the former vice president the
current president United States who can
declassify these documents with his mind
you [ __ ] rube didn't have the same
[ __ ] outrage you piece of [ __ ] that's
the difference
and the house Hunter lived in you mean
the golf resort that many people are
members right right were Kyle written
how's that murderous piece of [ __ ] and
other [ __ ] treasonous Congress people
were within within within reaching
distance of these documents you piece of
[ __ ] trash and and here's the thing
here's the thing you won't admit it that
you know your pre yeah [ __ ] you yeah
[ __ ] you too [ __ ] you can't even say it
hey you're you're such a [ __ ] you can't
even type [ __ ] you you [ __ ] little
[ __ ] listen this is the thing the
reason why you say [ __ ] you Tony is
because you don't have a real argument
you know the intent of stealing those
documents you know the reason why Donald
Trump is a treasonous piece of [ __ ] he
tried to over to throw our government
and our democracy because you hate
democracy you don't want equality you
don't want equity
that's why you love Donald Trump because
he's an authoritarian he's your [ __ ]
Jesus you get on your knees and you suck
him off suck his Cheeto you little [ __ ]
and you don't you don't admit that his
intent and his intent to obstruct and
the reason why he's obstructing is
because it's evidence you stupid [ __ ]
you treasonous piece of [ __ ] Don well he
might be in Russia so I don't know if
you're true I mean some people are
saying that John Tobin could be fake
Gabe don't know might be is God actually
George Santos being Don Cobin I don't
know but for people like Don Cohen who
are sober [ __ ] whatever whatever your
name is [ __ ] you Tony f you if you I
don't have an argument so if you you're
a little [ __ ] come up please come up
with some [ __ ] to type in you you
[ __ ] I mean a little snowflake actual
argument here because the other thing
too is when you have people like Jim
Jordan and you know other people
uh like uh that like Josh Hawley be like
oh special counsel special counsel
special counsel and then you're like why
wasn't his Home braided right because
the FBI went there got this [ __ ] he said
hey look we might have to come get this
[ __ ] come look for them he opened the
door just like Hillary Clinton was like
yeah come come get my server look at it
so when people like Don cope and another
Republican another mag of people want to
go oh what about our emails oh let's
rate his house
one person spent 18 months trying to
deceive Nara and the FBI and then
committed fraud there's going to be
lawyers that are not going to be lawyers
anymore
and then now you've got another person
Joe Biden the president where personal
lawyers found these things because they
were clearing out the office and then
they said all right we're gonna go look
into these other places and then they're
like yeah go look go do it go look FBI
come look I have nothing to hide I have
nothing to hide
I know I know I'm the best hands down I
understand this that's why Don comes
here and he gets pissed off tiny hands
down ready hands down I am the the best
there is in the biz In The Biz and so is
Gabe Sanchez
um he's the best co-host and the best
executive producer in the biz I guess
that makes me the best host
um I don't know he does a damn good job
of Hosting what was that I don't know if
you guys have been watching what was a
new one out today well go go take a look
um if you go to Gabe Sanchez's um
Twitter page I'll retweet that here in a
minute but the last thing I want to do
before we go because I've been talking
to you about this in private for the
last few days my timeline Gabe Sanchez
is yeah full is full this anti-vaxx
[ __ ] problem like there there are
some accounts uh that I have blocked
because they're just like completely
vile stuff and I just came through my
timeline like I don't know 20 minutes
ago I was around the show I was like
scrolling through
and I saw people that I was like no I
don't want to see their [ __ ] but they
showed up on my timeline yeah because
because one happened what did Elon break
well I mean uh the thing he did was the
the thing he did break was the the covet
thing because you weren't able to post
this [ __ ] on Twitter because it's it's
[ __ ] it's it's it's it's false it's
all [ __ ]
um let me see if I can find one of these
um
I can't find one of these posts that I'm
talking about uh one was the Chelsea
Handler oh this is a good one though you
sent me
um this is because what is really
happening and what they're scared of is
the fact that
anti-vaxxers are dying we know that
diamond from Diamond Hill silk uh kicked
the bucket
uh I danced on her grave
people got mad that I danced on her
grave I don't give a [ __ ] I don't give a
[ __ ] you piece of [ __ ] she's been
spreading propaganda that's killing
other people who are deluded into this
trumpism and this anti-back [ __ ] and
they continue this nonsense
um this is a post now is this the guy is
this the proud boy this is the problem
oh he's so proud guess what he's dead
now [ __ ] him
um says far right Trump loving covet
denying anti-vaxxer proud boy leading
member Aaron how do you say his name
lasagna has reportedly died from covid
um oh in that sad he's joining diamond
or no silk which one is it is it it's
diamond diamond well you know yeah you
know couldn't happen to a better person
this uh proud boy uh leading member oh
oh he got company died [ __ ] there was
there was a narrative this weekend it
was actually really interesting to watch
people were trying to push the idea that
Trump had done so much with the um
with the oh wow I'm blanking on the name
right now warp speed warp speed right
operation warp speed and then people
were like uh that would be the only
accomplishment that he had and then
other people would be like well how many
how many actual pharmaceutical companies
participated and benefit from that right
but then what came of people saying like
look you can't claim
a win for that if you yourself and the
party were pushing the idea that covet
was a hoax it was manufactured in a lab
in Wuhan China it was all made up it was
the government trying to give us 5G it
was the government trying to to do mind
control you can't push both narratives
and say Trump gets the W for for making
the or like helping make the vaccine but
then also saying Trump and Republicans
don't believe in the in the vaccine
because covet isn't real you can't have
both sides you can't push both [ __ ]
pedals at the same time well here's them
doing stupid [ __ ] like that I don't know
who this is or who this account is is
[ __ ] this vile piece of trash helped
by James
um he doesn't have he's got 46 000
followers but his [ __ ] has been showing
up in my [ __ ] feed and I'm sick of it
now it's all lies he's this is a [ __ ]
lie I want everyone lie detector lie
detector and then we're gonna have to go
because we're running out of time but
there's a ton of [ __ ] like this on this
guy's fee where he takes a video that
has nothing to do about [ __ ] covid
and vaccines and all this [ __ ] he makes
up some sort of [ __ ] fake ass story
he did this with Chelsea Handler's video
he did it with another comedian passing
out on stage there was all kinds of
videos that he's made that he's created
narratives and lies and stories around
these videos that are like a year two
years old three years old
um this one he says urgent as if we're
supposed to do something right now Gabe
Sanchez an Australian man hunts down a
doctor absolutely one of his family
members this is so familiar like we saw
this on yes this is from like a year ago
and it had nothing to do it had nothing
to do with his family member dying from
covid and this is the person in the car
is not a doctor this is a video and he
is presenting in narrative the boomerang
uh looks so familiar right attacking the
side mirror looks so familiar this was a
road rage road rage incident in
Australia that's why the boomerang I I
it's not it's it's kind of clich Shea
but yeah he did have a boomerang and he
was hitting the car with a boomerang but
this is a road rate inch roach rage
incident has nothing to do with gov it
has nothing to do with the doctor this
guy is making this [ __ ] up he's making
this [ __ ] up and it's propaganda they're
they're trying to [ __ ] Stoke a
narrative on Twitter and elon's letting
them of course um do this now that
account has done this um again with many
[ __ ] videos over the weekend
um and of course this is the best
Twitter can do
[Music]
yeah here's here's the note the man in
the video claimed he was suffering a
manic episode at the time of the
incident his brother was injured by
falling out of a window of his own house
he was not injured by vaccines instead
of saying oh we shouldn't show this
video we shouldn't promote this tweet
right because it's a lie it's an
outright light it's going to kill that's
gonna kill people yeah this is Elon Musk
being like look Community notes are
great guys look what they do and it's
like well if it really was great then
the community that you had originally to
ask hey Iman stick your community notes
straight up your [ __ ] ass yeah you
piece of [ __ ] okay so I want you to be
on the lookout for this stuff this
propaganda send it to me as you find it
we will debunk it we will go through it
because that video has nothing to
[ __ ] do with the vaccines and they're
trying to push their propaganda and
frankly they're killing people who are
believing this delusion which in some
aspects the ones that are pushing the
delusion I hope they kick the bucket
[ __ ] them because they've they've
they've made their own bed here so I'm
not sad about it you wanted to believe
this thing wasn't real and you wanted to
put yourself in danger
do what all the smart diners did go get
the vaccine and lie about getting it you
dummy you're gonna lie just lie why not
just lie just get the vaccine protect
yourself lie and then perpetuate your
stupidity but you know whatever so [ __ ]
around find out uh kick the bucket I'll
dance on Your Grave every mother [ __ ]
time just like I do every single weekday
here on the Tony Michaels podcast Newton
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific we are on
the road to 20 000 Gabe Sanchez we're
getting close to 14. please help us
audience share this link today with
three your friends three your family
members make sure don don if you're out
there you [ __ ] snowflake share it
with three of your your alpha male
buddies get them in the chat let's see
what they got you [ __ ] rube yeah so
go follow us and um
subscribe to YouTube need Tony Michaels
pot gas also follow us at Tony Michaels
pod on Twitter now and we'll keep up
with all the vinyl anti-vac [ __ ] there
also download every single episode Apple
Spotify goo your favorite directory
don't forget to leave us a review while
you're there subscribing and follow us
on Facebook hey Don come over to my
Facebook page invite all your buddies
yeah invite them come troll me [ __ ] you
[ __ ] [ __ ] at the Tony Michaels on
Facebook and also uh follow us on Twitch
Go download that app if you like chats
the chat's a little different over there
but make sure we're on the road to 20
000 on YouTube make sure you and your
friends and your family subscribe to the
Tony Michaels podcast we have to spread
this message all around the world and
you are the best audience in the world
the best moderators the best the most
greatest co-host and of course me
how can I not be the best of this until
tomorrow same place same time Surf's Up
[ __ ]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
area of current events and political
news no rules No Boundaries I think
we've made that perfectly clear we hope
you enjoyed the show and we'll be back
soon in the meantime follow toning on
social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
Murphy's muleborn head ass Beacon